don't spend so much time worrying about
what you're going to name your business
and instead focus on building a
successful foundation that can lead you
to huge growth hi I'm Evan Carmichael
your friend in all things
entrepreneurship and today i'm answering
a question from one of my readers are
geeth who's looking for a name for his
business and one of my help there's a
million different ways to go about this
if you look at any company and how they
got started how they found their name
you'll find a million different reasons
some people named the company after
themselves so mine is a mechanical calm
you can look at Harley Davidsons after
the two founders Harley and Davidson and
Ben & Jerry's ice cream some companies
are founded because it just make up a
word now some companies wanna work
that's easy to remember now Sony was the
combination of sonus and Sonny Boy and
so that became Sony a made-up word but
they wanted something that was easy to
remember some people make names that are
hard to remember but they realize that
once you remember you're never going to
forget it Xerox is an example of that
some people come up with a name because
of their situations if you look at
virgin they started because they were
all virgins in business there's a lot of
different ways to come up with a name
for your business and you can look at
any story again of any famous
entrepreneur how they got started and
where the name came from but I wouldn't
worry so much about the name maybe at
least find out that the domain name is
available that could be really important
but too often is entrence will get
caught up in the admin and the minutiae
of our business and we do the things
that we like to do instead of the things
that we have to do don't worry about the
name go and find a customer going to
find someone's going to pay you for what
you do that's the most important first
step right doesn't matter what your name
is that people aren't going to be
willing to pay you for your product or
service you don't have a company so go
and find that customer network with them
they won't care what you call the
business you got to be proud of your
company and i'm not saying just pick a
name from the air but this should not be
your top business priority
you might disagree with me I'm open to
hearing your feedback might be a little
controversial but for me my opinion I
wouldn't worry so much about the name
and again focus on the task one two
three most important things that you
need to grow your business finding a
company name is not gonna be on the top
of that list hopefully that helps I love
do you guys have to think leave a
comment let me know and if you like the
video please give it a thumbs up below
it always makes me happy when I see them
come in and want to do more videos for
you guys let's see you soon
you